[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في حصاده الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات مدن
وعواصم في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث مهمه
البدايه من العاصمه الاوكرانيه التي تتهم
سلطاتها روسيا بشن هجوم صاروخيا على
العاصمه والتي تعيش ايضا على وقع حديث
السلطات المواليه لروسيا عن قصف اوكراني
على ماريوبول
وهذه الصور من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
بعد اعلان وزاره الدفاع التعبئه العامه
لمتقاعدي الجيش ووقوع اشتباكات متقطعه
وقصف مدفعي وسماعي مضادات ارضيه
هذه الصور من مدينه اسطنبول التي تعيش
وتستعد مع بقيه المدن التركيه لجوله
الاعاده في الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
يتنافس فيها كل من الرئيس التركي ومرشح
تحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان ومرشح
تحالف الشعب كمال
وفي مواضيع الحصاد بهذه الليله
بعد اتهامه بالتضليل وتشجيع حمادتي على
التمرد البرهان يطلب من الامين العام
للامم المتحده ابعاد ممثله بالسودان فولك
واختيار بديل له ووسط الشبكات المتقطعه
وقصف المدفعي في الخرطوم وام درمان وزاره
الدفاع تعلن التعبئه العامه لمتقاعدي
الجيش ومصدر عسكري بالجيشه السوداني يقول
للجزيره انه صادر اسلحه وذخائر بولايه
البحر الاحمر شرقي البلاد قادمه من دوله
اجنبيه
السلطات المواليه لروسيا تقول ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استهدفت
وفي حاكم المقاطع يقول ان طائره مسيره
القت قذيفتين متفجرتين على احدى المناطق
واوكرانيا تعلن حاجتها الى 48 مقاتله اف
16 بما وصفته بتحرير اراضيها
مواجهات بين شرطه كوسوفو ومواطنين من اصل
صربي تشعل توترا جديدا في البلقان اوامر
للجيش الصربي بالتاهب القتالي والاقتراب
من الحدود مع كوسوفو
تتهم بنغلاد بالتصعيد وتحملها مسؤوليه
تعريض السلام والاستقرار للخطر الاتحاد
الاوروبيين وواشنطن تصف اجراءات كوسوفو
بالتصعيد غير الضروري وتدعو الى الامتناع
عن اي خطوات تؤجج الصراع
في لقاء اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصات
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم العقوبات
الامريكيه التي فرضتها واشنطن على مجموعه
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه بضوء مقالته
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه من ان فاجنر تزود
قوات الدعم السريع بصواريخ ارض جو لمواجهه
الجيش السوداني والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التاليه والسؤال يقول هل ستؤثر العقوبات
الامريكيه على دعم باجنر لقوات الدعم
السريعه الاجابات جاءت على النحو التالي
نحو 12% قالوا انها ستؤثر بقوه بينما قال
نحو 23% ان التاثير سيكون محدودا
بما صوت نحو
65% بالقول ان العقوبات لن تؤثر باي حال
من الاحوال هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد ايضا
في اجواء استقطاب حاده قبيله جوله الاعاده
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه اردوغان
يقول ان انتخابه يضمن تركيا قويه
ينفي ما سماها اتهامات الحزب الحاكم له
بالعلاقه مع المنظمات الارهابيه
[موسيقى]
البدايه من السودان حيث طالب رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو بترشيح بديل لممثله
الخاص في السودان وذلك للحفاظ على العلاقه
التي تربط المؤسسه الدوليه بالسودان
البرهان قال في رساله وجهها
سلبيا عن دورا عن دور الامم المتحده
وحيادها واحترامها لسياده الدول ملتهما
بممارسه مواسفه بالتضليل والتدليس في
تقاريره للامم المتحده بزعمه ان هناك
اجماعا بشان الاتفاق الايطالي واضاف
البرهان في رسالته الى الامين العام
للمنظمه الدوليه بانهم ما كان لرئيس قوات
الدعم السريع حميتي ان يتمرد لو لم يجد
اشارات تشجيعيه من عدد من الاطراف من
بينها
مشيرا الى انه للحفاظ على العلاقه بين
الامم المتحده والسودان تطالب الخرطوم
بتعيين بديل لفو
هذا وقد دعت وزاره الدفاع السودانيه كل
المتقاعدين من القوات المسلحه الى دعم
الجهود العسكريه والتوجه الى اقرب وحده
عسكريه اعتبارا من الاثنين المقبل
لتسليحهم في غضون ذلك قال مصدر عسكري
بالجيش السوداني للجزيره انهم صادروا
اسلحه وذخائر بولايه البحر الاحمر الشرقيه
البلاد قادمه من دوله اجنبيه واضاف ان
المجموعات التي تم القبض عليها تتعامل مع
المتمردين لامدادهم من الخارج يتزامن ذلك
مع اشتباكات متقطعه وقصف مدفعي في الخرطوم
وام درمان
هدات ولم تتوقف المعارك بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في اسبوع
اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار استمرار المواجهات
سيقوض هدنه انتزعت بشق الانفس وتراهن
واشنطن والرياض على ضروره نجاحها انخفت
صوت الرصاص والمدفعيه في الساعات الاخيره
فان الوضع هش بالرغم من تعهدات المتقاتلين
وتحذيرات المراقبين تبقى شوارع الخرطوم
خليه من مظاهر الحياه الطبيعيه خشيه
استئناف المعارك او التعرض للسلب والنهب
من المبكرين نسيان ما حدث من انتهاكات
خلال الايام الماضيه يحاول الجيش تعزيز
صفوفه في حرب يبدو انها ستكون اطول مما
توقعه واكثر شرسه من حساباته الاوليه قال
وزير الدفاع السوداني سن ابراهيم ياسين في
بيان للوزاره انه تقرر استدعائه كل
المتقاعدين من الجيش لدعم الجهود العسكريه
يشمل الاستدعاء الضباط والضباط الصف
والجنود الذين لا تزيد اعمارهم عن 65 عاما
شريطه التوفر لياقه الطبيه والبدنيه
والقدره على حمل واستخدام السلاح ودعاهم
للتوجه الى اقرب وحده عسكريه اعتبارا من
الاثنين القادم وكان بيان وزاره الدفاع
ذكر بالتفصيل اعتداءات قوات الدعم السريع
على المقر الدبلوماسيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
ومكاتب بعض المنظمات الدوليه والمستشفيات
تتكرر هذه الاتهامات منذ اكثر من اربعين
يوما في حرب يحمل فيها كل طرف الاخر
مسؤوليه الفوضى التي تعم العاصمه ومدن
اخرى في البلاد مثل دارفور
وتعقيدات المشهد لم تمنع الوسطاء
السعوديين والامريكيين من رؤيه تحسن ملحوظ
احترام اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق النار وجاء في
بيانهم المشترك ان الرياض واشنطن تواصلت
مع طرفي النزاع بعد الانتهاكات ولفتت الى
ان تجدد القتال عرض المدنيين للخطر واعق
المساعدات الانسانيه وحذرت الطرفين من
مزيد من الانتهاكات ونشدت تحسين احترام
اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق النار سبق ان لوحت
الاداره الامريكيه بفرض عقوبات على
المزعزعين لاستقرار السودان واللافت ان
الاتفاق الاخير لوقف اطلاق النار ينص على
اليه للمراقبه ولكن لم يتخذ اي اجراء بحق
احد الطرفين رغم كثره الخروقات
الحوار هو الحل وغير مستحيل ربما هذا ما
يفهم من احدث التصريحات لممثل بعثه الامم
المتحده لدعم الانتقال بالسودان
اليه هناك ادراك لدى الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع ان استمرار القتال بينهما لن
يقوده للنتيجه المرشوبه وانه لا مفر لهما
من المفاوضات لانهاء الحرب وايجاد حلول
واقعيه للخلاف على حد تعبيره وحدد اولويات
الامم المتحده ومن بينها وقف القتال
وتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه للمحتاجين
والمساعده وتسهيل حوار سياسي جديد اذا لزم
الامر تريد المنظمه الاغاثيه ممرا امنا
لايصال المساعدات في بلد يعيش ازمات
انسانيه كبيره حتى قبل هذه الحرب لابد من
اسكات السلاح لانها مساله حياه او موت
هكذا جاءت صيغه دعوه منظمه الصليب الاحمر
الدولي
لتسهيل عملها
ومعنى من الخرطوم مراسلنا اسامه سيد احمد
اهلا بك اسامه هل من تفاصيل بخصوص هذه
الاسلحه التي تمت مصادرتها في البحر
الاحمر
بولايه البحر الاحمر طبعا وهي قادمه من
الخارج
بالنسبه لهذه الاسلحه يعني بحسب مصدر
عسكري اكد للجزيره ان انه رصد نشاطا
لمجموعات في شرق السودان تقوم في هذا
النشاط بتهريب السلاح
والاستخبارات العسكريه
بولايه البحر الاحمر قال انها تلاحق
مجموعات تعمل على ادخال اسلحه ودقائق في
المناطق الشرقيه من البلاد وتقوم بايصال
هذه الاسلحه من وصفهم بالمتمردين المصدر
ايضا اشار الى ان
الاستخبارات العسكريه التابعه للجيش
السوداني تمكنت اليوم مساء من القبض على
مجموعه من الاسلحه والدخائر جنوب منطقه
سواكن بولايه البحر الاحمر قادمه من دوله
اجنبيه لم يحدد هذه الدوله الاجنبيه
بطبيعه الحال
وذكر كذلك ان المجموعات التي تم القاء
القبض عليها تتعامل مع من سماهم المتمردين
لايصال الامداد الخارجي لهم هذه واحده من
التطورات يعني المتلاحقه خلال هذا اليوم
فيما يتعلق باستمرار الحرب ما بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه الحرب ليست
في ميدان المعركه فقط هناك حرب دبلوماسيه
وهناك حرب تصريحات هنا وهناك وهناك ايضا
حرب لبيانات من الجيش السوداني واخرى من
قوات الدعم السريع يعني هذه تطورات يعني
دبلوماسيه متلاحقه وهناك تطورات ايضا
ميدانيه ايضا متلاحقه قلنا خلال ساعات
الماضيه كنا نتحدث خاصه في ساعات النهار
كنا نتحدث عن هدنه تبدو متماسكه ولكن فيما
يبدو ان هذه الهدنه اصبحت ليست متماسكه
خاصه هناك بعض كان هناك تحليق
الطيران الحربي
الذي يعني اجابه
مساحات واسعه في الواقع من مناطق متفرقه
شكرا لك اسامه سيد احمد شكرا لك
انضم الى الان من ام درمان احمد عمر خوجلي
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وانضم الينا من
شيكاغو وعسل ابو عسل الكاتب والباحث
السياسي والطبع طبعا الحديث الان هو عن
هذه الرساله التي بعثها البرهان للامين
العام للامم المتحده يطالب باستبدال
فولكر بيرس مبعوث الامم المتحده للسودان
وفي التصريح للمتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده للجزيره قال بانك وتيرش
مصدوم مصدوم هذا هو التعبير مصدوم من هذه
الرساله التي وصلته من البرهان نسال سيد
خوجلي عن المستندات التي ارتكز عليها
البرهان في رسالته الى الامين العام للامم
المتحده
عليكم السلام ورحمه الله
برهان وردتها حكومته في الفتره الاخيره
حيال نشاط مبعوث الامم المتحده في السودان
وعدم الرضا ظهر في الفتره الاخيره من خلال
البيان الاخير في مجلس الامن اذ ان
المبعوث لم يشير باي حال من الاحوال على
تجاوزات والدعم السريع وعلى انتهاكاتها
المختلفه يعني تصريع بشكل واضح امام خطابه
الاخير المساله الاخرى التي استند عليها
البرهان وحكومته في
مطالبتهم بابدال المبعوث
هو ان
المبعوث اعطى المشروعيه لقوات الدعم
السريعي من خلال توقيع على الايطالي كجسم
منفصل ليس كتائب القوات المسلحه وهذه هذه
اعطت
قوه الدعم السريع اداه قوه في موقفها
السياسي واعطاها النديه للقوات المسلحه
التي كان من المفترض ان تكون تابعا للقوات
المسلحه هذه ثانيه
الماخذ الاخرى هي ان البعثه لم لم تلتزم
بكثير من الالتزامات التي جاءت من اجلها
احيانا الوضع الاقتصادي والودع الاجتماعي
بل انها من خلال الكثير من الملاحظات
والنشاطات التي قام بها المبعوث يعني
اظهرت انحيازا يعني
لمجموعه الاطار مع دعمها
واعطائها المشروعيه لقوات الدعم السريع في
توقيعها كقيام منفصل هي اظهرت ميلا واضحا
احيان القوه التي
يعني تتشكل من احزاب الموقعه لاتفاق
الاطاري وهذا يعني كان له الدور الاكبر في
الحماس الذي عبدته هذه القوه في في
الوقوع تحت مظله الدعم السريع ومحاوله ان
يكون لها رافعه
قد تنقلها الى السلطه خالصه
للسيد ابو عسل ما اذا كانت فعلا هناك
مؤشرات تدل على انحياز المبعوث الاممي
للقوات المناوبه للجيش اساسا قوات الدعم
السريع ومن يواليها من الاطراف السياسيه
شكرا على الاستضافه
هيئه الامم المتحده هي منظمه عالميه لا
تنحاز الى دوله ولا تنحاز الى جهه ولا
تنحاز الى اي طرف في اي صراع هذا امر ثابت
ومعروف
وبالتالي فانه مبعوث الامين العام لدى
السودان وهو لم يبعث في هذه الفتره
الاخيره اثناء قيام هذه الحرب او بعدها هو
ظل في السودان لفتره طويله وعاصر التحول
الذي تم في السودان بعد الثوره انتصار
الثوره واسقاط الديكتاتور عمر البشير ولكن
استمرار
بقايا نظام عمر بشير السابق داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه وفي المؤسسات المدنيه وفي
كتائبهم للظل ظلوا على الدوام يناسبون
مبعوث الامين العام للامم المتحده الاعداء
ويطالبون بطرده وراينا كيف انهم ان ظهر
احد رجالهم احد رجالهم
وطلب ان تصدر الفتوى له حتى يقوم باغتيان
السيد الم العام السيد المبعوث الامين
العام للامم المتحده ولذلك هذا الحديث لا
اساس له من الصحه السيد امين العام ليس
سوداني ولا
مبعوثه سوداني او ينتمي الى اي جهه او اي
منطقه او اي مدينه في السودان وليس له اي
مصلحه في ينحاز الى طرف او اخر او ينحاز
الى الدعم السريع ولكن من الواضح انه شهد
بعينه كيفيه النقوص عن المواثيق والعقود
التي يقوم بها قاده الجيش ومن خلفهم
بقايا النظام السابق الذين يؤازرونهم
والذين تسببوا في اشعال هذه الحرب التي
ازهقت الكثير من انفس البريئه في السودان
وقاده الى كثير من الدمار والتدمير الذي
يجري الان في السودان نعم مثلما اشرت
السيد خوجلي قبل قليل من ان ربما اخر ما
ابداه
مبعوث الامين العام من انحياز كما تقول
ظهر في الاحاطه التي قدمها في مجلس الامن
فعلا عندما ترى وتطالع هذه الاحاطه كلها
تتحدث عن طرفي الصراع لم يشر باصبع
الاتهام لا للجيش ولا الى قوات الدعم
السريع ولكن هذا هو ديدن المبعوثين
الدوليين دائما سواء في ليبيا سواء في
سوريا او غيرها لا يريدون اتهام طرف بعينه
بشكل مباشر حتى تبقى لهم وساطه فاعله اذا
لماذا لم يؤخذ هذا بعين الاعتبار من قبل
البرهان والجيش
الحراك السياسي الاخير الذي يعني
انتظر فيه المبعوث الاممي في السودان يعني
وصلت منه كثير من الاشارات للاعلام من
خلال التصريحات التي ينصرها على الوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ومؤسسه الاعلام الصحفيه
ان هناك يعني تحاملا على الجيش السوداني
وبدا من خلال الكثير من الاشارات التي
تواترت خلال فتره طويله
الحياد ينبغي ان يكون يعني متساويا بين
الطرفين
الاحاطات
والاخبار الصحفيه والتصريحات التي كانت
يعني تترا من مكتب السيد المبعوث كانت
تتحامل على الجيش وتتخذ موقفا مساويا
للقوه المدنيه
واضح من واضح من تفاعل الامين العام سيد
جوديرش الذي قال على لسان المتحدث باسمه
انه مصدوم انه لن لن يتفاعل ايجابيا مع
هذا الطلب علما علما وان السيد البره في
ابريل من العام الماضي طالب ايضا اللوحه
لنقل لوحه بطرد المبعوث الدولي اذا القصه
فيها عداء قديمه لحد ما
والله مع الجيوش مع القوات المسلحه في زمن
انتقال صعب كما تمر به البلاد الان زمن
يعني صمام الامان فيه وكثير من التحديات
الخارجيه والداخليه يعني تلتف حول حول
البلاد الحديث المباشر عن الفهم
الديمقراطي والفكره الديمقراطي التي تعبر
عنه الامم المتحده في كثير من انشطتها
المختلفه وفي رؤاها وفي اجنداتها المعروفه
دائما يجعل يجعلها في مواجهه مع الجيوش
لكن في الحاله السودانيه كان ينبغي ان
تراعى حاله الانتقال وحاله الحشاش الامنيه
وحاله التحديات الكبيره والحروب القبليه
اذا رعي هذا كان يمكن ان يبدو المبعوث
محايدا تماما ومراعيا لظروف الخاصه التي
تمر بها البلاد ولكن المطالبه الصرفه
للنظام الديمقراطي باعجل ما تيسر وباي
طريقه كانت كانه البلاد بلا تحديات هذه
هذا هذا هذا هو الظلم الذي وقع على الجيش
السوداني
لنرى بعد اذنك يعني لنرى ماذا اذا كان
السيد ابو عسل يعتقد بان
موقف الامم المتحده المتحفظ لنقل على
الاقل او المعارض لهذه الرساله من البرهان
يمكن ان تكون له تداعيات في الفتره
المقبله في السودان
ربما اذا كان السيد البرهان ومن معه من
قاده الجيش ومن كبار قاده الجيش
ومن يقف خلفهم من بقايا النظام السابق
وقادته اذا تعاملوا مع هذه مع هذه
التقارير في مسؤوليه
واستصحبوا في اثناء تعامله بهذا مصلحه
السودان والسودانيين ربما يحدث تغيير
ايجابي من جانبهم لان التقرير بشكل واضح
ابان خروقاتهم ابان النقاط تقصيرهم ونقاط
اخطائهم وعليهم التعامل بمسؤوليه ولكن من
الواضح انهم لا يتعاملون بمسؤوليه حتى
الان مع كل ما يحدث راينا ان الجهه
الوحيده التي تمتلك سلاحا للطيران في هذا
النزاع المسلح المؤلم او المؤسف الذي يدور
في السودان حاليا والذي يروح ضحيته في
الاساس ضحيته في الاساس المواطنون العزل
الابياء هو الجهه هو القوات المس التي
تمتلك سلاح الطيران وهو قد استهدف البنيات
التحتيه للبلاد من مصانع واسواق واستهدف
حتى بيوت الابرياء والعزل والمدنيين شكرا
تاكيد ان مثل هذا في الحقيقه لا يمكن
انكارها من قبل الجيش ولا بد انها ذكرت في
تقارير السيد شكرا لك سيد بو عسل ابو عسل
من شيكاغ ونعتذر لم نتمكن من اخرك صوتا
وصوره وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من ام درمان احمد
عمر خوجلي
[موسيقى]
في تطوراته حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
سلطات المواليه لروسيا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استهدفت محيط مصنع ازوغستال في
مدينه ماريوبول بصاروخين بعيدي المدى ولم
يسفر القصف وفق السلطات عن اي اضرار وفي
الروسيه قال حاكم المقاطعه ان طائره مسيره
القت قضيفتين متفجرتين على احدى المناطق
هذا وقد نشر ما يطلق على نفسه اسم فيلق
حريه روسيا مقطعا يظهر جانبا مما قال انها
عمليات في
وتظهر الصور التوغل عناصر من الفيلق داخل
واستهداف عناصر واليات من القوات الروسيه
كما توثق الصور ما قال الفيلق انه استهداف
لجنود الروس احتموا بالمنازل السكنيه في
تلك المقاطعه
خيم تبادل الاتهامات بين روسيا واوكرانيا
بقصف اهداف مدنيه على ابرز التطورات
الميدانيه التي شهدتها ساحات المعارك
المستمره بين الجانبين اذ اعلنت الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في العاصمه ان هجوم
الروسيا بصواريخ كروز استهدف المدينه وان
دفاعات الجويه تمكنت من تدمير جميع
الصواريخ التي اطلقت من بحري قزوين في
مقاطعه التي تحل اليوم الذكرى التاسعه
لاندلاع القتال لاول مره فيها بين القوات
المواليه لروسيا والجيش الاوكراني اتهمت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه
باستهداف سد كارلفيكا القريب من مدينه
باربعه صواريخ من طراز اس 300 محذره من ان
ذلك قد يتسبب باغراق المناطق والبلدات
المجاوره
في حين اتهم عمده المقاطعه الموالي لروسيا
اوكرانيا بقصف مركز البحوث العلمي ما تسبب
بمقتل شخص واصابه اثنين فضلا عن وقوع
اضرار كبيره في المكان
الاتهامات الاوكرانيه لموسكو بقصف اهداف
مدنيه امتدت الى مقاطعه دينيبرو جنوب
الشرقي البلاد اذ اعلن رئيس الاداره
العسكريه للمقاطعه مقتل شخصين واصابه 23
اخرين في قصف روسي اصاب منشاه طبيه وقد
وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
قصف المنشاه بالعمل الارهابي في المقابل
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بيلغرود الروسيه تعرضا
منطقتين حدوديتين في المقاطعه لقصف
اوكراني الحق اضرارا بعدد من المباني
السكنيه وخطوط امداد الغاز والطاقه
الكهربائيه هناك دون وقوع اصابات بشريه
كما اعلن حاكم اقليم كران جنوبيه روسيا
تحطم مسيرتين في اجواء المدينه ما تسبب في
اضرار ماديه باحد المباني بعيدا عن
الاهداف المدنيه قالت قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه انها كثفت قصفها على مواقع
القوات الروسيه على الضفه الشرقيه من نهر
دنيبر بمقاطعه خرسون وانها نجحت في تكبيد
القوات الروسيه خسائر في الارواح والعتاد
في حين بدا لافتا اعلان قائد مجموعه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه يفجين انه تم
تكليف قواته بالقتال على جبهه جديده دون
ان يقدم مزيدا من المعلومات عن تلك الجبهه
واكتفى قائد المجموعه التي بدات منذ ايام
تسليم مواقعها في باخموت للقوات النظاميه
الروسيه بالقول ان الوطن يحتاج الينا
للدفاع عنه
متابعه لهذه التطورات تنضم الينا من موسكو
والسيده alger استاذه العلاقات الدوليه
بجماعه الابحاث الوطنيه ومن كيف الدكتور
ايفان اوس كبير الباحثين في المعهد
الاوكراني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا
بهما ونبدا من موسكو والسيده كريسنياك هذا
الاستهداف الاوكراني داخل الاراضي
الروسيه في بيلوجراد ما مدى خطورته
صعبه وجاده فعلا والقول اننا لا نعتني
بهذا سيكون غير حقيقي اننا نقوي
بانظمه انضمنتنا وقدراتنا الدفاعيه في
الداخل وعلى الحدود هناك بعض التغييرات في
التكتيكات
العسكريه
والمسيرات اصبحت مهمه جدا لذلك يجب ان
نستخدم الوسائل التي تصدها هذه الهجمات
التكنولوجيا تتطور ونحن نفهم هذا ونقوم
بالاجراءات اللازمه حتى نصد هذه الهجمات
الاوضاع فعلا جديه ولكننا مستعدين لها
ونقوم بكل ما في وسعنا حتى نصد هذه
الهجمات الوصول الى
استهداف اليات وجنود روس داخل التراب
الروسي هل تخشى موسكو ان يتطور اكثر في
الفتره المقبله
يعني
كلمه الخشيه مناسبه هنا
نحن لا نخشى احد نحن لا نشعر بالذعر
ولكننا نتعامل بعقلانيه
وندافع عن مصالحنا حتى ندافع عن الاراضي
ولكن اريد ان الفت الانتباه على جانب اخر
من هذه الهجمات المتزايده وخاصه في وسائل
الاعلام ربما تكون هذه جزء من الحرب
الاعلاميه من الطرف الاوكراني حتى تقوم
بلفت الانتباه الى امور اخرى بعيدا عن
الانتصار في ضخمه الذي انتظرناه طويلا
فهذه هي الهجمات بالمسيرات قد تكون تاكيدا
ان
تاكيدا
للشركاء الغربيين من طرف اوكرانيا انهم
يقوموا ببعض العمليات
النظر عن السبب نحن مستعدين نصد هذه
الهجمات وسوف نغير التكتيكات عندما نحتاج
لهذا السؤال الاخير سيدك
قول فاقنر بانها ستنتقل الان لجبهه اخرى
ما توقعاتك ماذا يمكن ان تكون هذه الجبهه
فعلا قال انه سوف يشارك باشياء وامور
جديده وان لديهم مهمات جديده ولكن لم يكن
هناك اي حديث او تحديد للجبهات الجبهه هي
واحده في الواقع كبيره جدا ما الهدف من
اعاده تمركز فاجنر سوف نعلم سوف نعرف هذا
قريبا ولكن سوف نرى هذا في الوقت القريب
ماذا كان يقصد السيد بريجوجن شكرا جزيلا
لك السيده اولغا كريس نياك من موسكو الان
ننتقل الى ضيفنا من كييف الدكتور ايفان
هاوس واضح ان كيف تراهن
على صفقه الاف 16 حتى تقوم بتحول نوعي
وتحرير اراضيها كما تقول هل فعلا يمكن ان
تكون الصوره بهذا الشكل
مساء الخير من كييفو
ارحب بكم
وارحب بكم
وبالمستمعين بالطبع ظهور الافتس 16 هذا
سوف يكون له دور كبير جدا
في بدايه الحرب كان هناك اهميه للمسيرات
بيرقدار
وصواريخ الجافلين ثم
عندما حصلت اوكرانيا على الهايمرز هذا
اصبح
شيء غير
قواعد اللعبه
الان
الدبابات اصبحت لها اهميتها والمراحل
القادمه هي المقاتلات بالطبع دون مقاتلات
جيده من الصعب ان تعتمد اوكرانيا على فكره
تحرير جميع الاراضي لذلك اخترنا الاف 16
وطلبنا بكميات كبيره منها وطلبنا ان
يعجلوا بتسليم جزء من هذه الكميات اعتقد
انها في العمليات الجديده باستخدام هذه
الطائرات سوف يكون هناك نجاح اكبر ولكن
معروف سيد دكتوراه السلاح الطيران من
الصعب ان يحسم اي معركه بمعنى حتى لو كانت
النتائج قويه في الشرق الاوكراني هذا
يحتاج الى تقدم بري وهذا مساله ربما محل
تساؤل الان
فعلا دون المشاه من المستحيل
الفوز في الحرب ولكن
ما هو دور ضخمه لماذا كنا نحتاج للصمود في
باخموت كنا نحتاج الوقت
خسرت
خسرت روسيا المئات الالاف من قواتها
وكنا نحضر جنودنا وندربهم مع المتخصصين
الغربيين والخبراء الان
الدبابات التي حصلنا عليها والخبراء الذين
دربناهم هذا سوف يكون
نواه الهجمات العكسيه القادمه
بالطبع الهجمات في الداخل
الروسي بما فيها هذه محاوله
لتشديد قوات الجيش الروسي وعندها سوف نحصل
على فرص لهجمات ناجحه شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور ايفان
[موسيقى]
في كوسوفو اندلعت مواجهتهم بين الشرطه
والمواطنين من اصول صربيا احرقت فيها
سيارات للشرطه في البلديات الشماليه على
الحدود مع صربيا وقالت الشرطه في بيان لها
انها تتخذ اجراءات وتدابير لمنع جميع
الانشطه الاجراميه في البلد وتقدم
المساعده ببلديات شان واليوزابيك
الشماليه من جهه اخرى اعلن الرئيس الصربي
الكسندر فشيش وضع الجيش في حاله تاهب
قتالي قصوى وامر وحداته بالاقتراب من
الحدود مع كسه في مقاله وزير الدفاع
انه اصدر اوامر بتحرك قواته عاجلا الى
حدود كتبه مضيفا ان من الواضح ان الارهاب
كما قال يستهدف الطاقه الصربيه في كوسوفو
من جهاته حمل كبير الموظفين في رئاسه
كوسوفو
حمل صربيا مسئوليه التصعيد في المناطق
الشماليه من كتبه وقال كبير موظفي الرئاسه
في كوسوفو في تغريده ان اي محاوله للتسلل
من قبل عسكريين صرب في زي مدني الى شمال
البلاد ستعرض السلامه والاستقرار في
المنطقه للخطر متهما النظام السربي بتصعيد
الوضع لضمان بقائه على حد تعبيره من جانبه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انه يدين بشده
الاجراءات التي اتخذتها حكومه كوسوفو
للوصول الى مباني البلديه في شمال بالقوه
واضاف ان هذه الاجراءات اتخذت كوسوفو رغم
نصيحه الولايات المتحده وشركاء كوسوف
الاوروبيين واشار بلينكن الى ان هذه
الاجراءات ادت الى تصعيد التوتر بشكل حاد
وبشكل غير ضروري كما ساهمت في تقويض
الجهود للمساعده في تطبيع العلاقات بين
كسه وصربيا موضحا انه ستكون لها عواقب على
علاقات الولايات المتحده مع كوسوفو ودع
بلينكن رئيس وزراء كوسوفو الى التراجع عن
تلك الاجراءات كما دعا جميع الاطراف الى
الامتناع عن اي اجراءات اخرى من شانها
اشعال التوترات
وتاجيج الصراع كما دان الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاشتباكات بين المتظاهرين والشرطه شمال
كوسوفو فيما شجب الهجمات على دوريات
البعثه المدنيه للاتحاد الاوروبي وقال
الاتحاد في بيان له انه يجب على الجميع
اتخاذ اجراءات لتهدئه الموقف المتوتر
واستعاده الهدوء على الفور
ينضم الينا الان من سراييفو مراسل الجزيره
احمد بجيتش احمد ما اخر الاخبار الوارده
من هذه المنطقه
الاخيره التي تشير الى
هدوء حذر في منطقه الشمال الكوسوفو او في
ثلاثه بليليات في شمال البلاد التي شهدت
تطورات او التوترات منذ منتصف النهار بعد
محاوله الشرطه الكوسوفيه بادخال السلطات
الجديده الى مقرات السلطه في تلك البلديات
هذه تطورات جاءت بعد
انتخابات المحليه التي اجريت في نهايه شهر
الماضي عندما انسحبت جميع ممثلين الصرب او
من قمية الصرب من تلك البلديات وقاموا
بمقاطعه عمل تلك البلديات اذن قام هناك
سلطات محليه بعمليه التصويت والانتخابات
المحليه وكان هناك ما يقارب واربعه في
المياه فقط من المصوتين
وفي نهايه المطاف نتائج تشير الى فوز فوز
الاقليه الالبانيه في تلك البلديات اذن
للاسف توقف البث من سرايف وشكرا لك احمد
كنت معنا من
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من لندن السيده دونيكا الباحثه
المختصه في شؤون البلقان اهلا وسهلا بك هل
يمكن ان تتفجر الاوضاع في شمال كوسوفو
اكثر مما شاهدناه الى حد الان
اما بكل تاكيد ليست هذه الموجه الاولى من
التصعيد ما بين كوسوفو صربيا كنت
سلفا في مجموعه من المقابلات العامه
الماضي ايضا
وراينا التوتر في ذلك الوقت كان هناك
صدامات ما بين صربيا وايضا ما بين
شمال كوسوفو خلال العشرين سنه الماضيه
كانت هناك سلسله من
المناوشات واعتقد ان الكره الان في مرمى
وايضا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من اجل
تخفيف التوتر الذي يشتعل بين
الاخرى واعتقد ان حكومه
تريد ان تعزز تواجدها وقوتها في شمال
كوسوفو وعلى الجانب الاخر الصربيه ايضا
تريد ان تعزز تواجدها في تلك المنطقه نعم
نعرف ان صربيا ورئيس وجه الكثير من
المشاكل
ان يدفع باتجاه الحدود نحو
ومن الضروري ان يكون هناك تخفيف
التصعيد
التوتر نعرف ان صربيا حليف قريب لروسيا
ونحن نعرف ان في اوروبا ان صربيا
وبيلاروسيا يبقى يعني الحليفين المقربين
مثلما اشرت موقف الاداره الامريكيه موقف
الاتحاد الاوروبي هل يمكن ان يسهما في وقف
التصعيد عند هذا الحد خاصه وان الجيش
الصربي الان على الحدود مع شمال كوسوفو
نعم هذا صحيح الكره في ملعب الاتحاد
الاوروبي والمتحده الامريكيه يجب ان نذكر
بان قوات النيتو موجوده على الارض منذ
نهايه الحرب واعتقد ان نتحدث عن حرب مع
كوسوفو ولكن حرب مع النيتو واعتقد ان قوه
النيت المسؤوله على توفير الامن والسلام
في المنطقه حسب قرار المتحده واعتقد ان هو
من المسؤوليه الاتحاد الاوروبي باعتبار
الاتحاد الاوروبي يقود جهد السلامه في
المنطقه حتى يكون هناك استقرار وتعايش ما
بين كوسوفو وصربيا ليس فقط الامراض يؤثر
فقط على صربيا ولكن على المنطقه برمتها ما
يحدث الان
انا هناك ازمه في الحقيقه بعد
اتفاقين وتفاهمين ما بين كوسوفو والصربيا
هناك تفهمها كان في شهر فبراير واخر في
مارس هذا العام وهذا اعطاء الامل ان
القنوات الدبلوماسيه تمكن من الوصول الى
حل على عكس ذلك نرى الان التوتر وهناك
مخاوف من وقوع المزيد
وهذا لن يتوقف الا اذا كان هناك تفاقات
دائم ما بين الطرفين شكرا لك سيده دونك من
لندن
[موسيقى]
تواصلوا الاحزاب والتحالفات التركيه
استعداداتها لجوله الاعاده للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقرره الاحد وقد دعا الرئيس
التركي ومرشح وتحالف الجمهور رجب طيب
اردوغان دع الشعب التركي للاحتشادي عند
الصناديق والتصويت له بكثافه واضاف
اردوغان في تجمع الانتخابي باسطنبول
باسطنبول ان انتخابه لجوله جديده يضمن ما
سماها تركيا القويه والعظيمه
في المقابل نفى زعيم وحزب الشعب الجمهوريه
ومرشح تحالف الشعب كمال كالجدار اوغلو ما
سماها اتهامات الحزب الحاكم له بعلاقته
بالمنظمات الارهابيه في اشاره لحزب العمال
الكردستاني وفي تغريده قالت لجدار اوغلو
ان ما يصدر بهذا الشان ما هو الا محض
افتراء حسب تعبيره
خمس نقاط مئويه كانت هي الفارقه بين
الرئيس التركي الحالي اردوغان متقدما بها
على منافسه مرشح تحالف المعارضه كما
الكلجدر نصف نقطه فقط كان كافيا ليبقي
مفاتيح القصر الجمهوري في يده لكنه وجد
نفسه مضطرا لخوض جوله اعاده عسى ان يحسم
الامر لصالحه بدء
[موسيقى]
الفرنسي
انتهج الرئيس استراتيجيه لا تختلف كثيرا
عن تلك التي اتبعها في الجوله الاولى من
السباق الرئاسي بدا من تركيزه على انه
القادر على اعاده اعمار المناطق التي
دمرتها الزلازل الاخيره الى تجديده الوعود
بنقل تركيا الى مصاف الدول المتقدمه
بالتزامن مع انطلاقه المئويه الثانيه
لجمهوريتها
اوراقه الرابحه على الطاوله منذ الجوله
الاولى من الصناعات الدفاعيه الى اتهامات
المعارضه بمحاباه الارهاب الى ادائه في
مناطق الزلزال هو مرتاح وليس هناك ضروره
ليخرج من قبعه الساحر ارنبا
في المقابل بدت لهجته كمالك اكثر تصعيدا
حيث انتهج خطابا متشددا تجاه اللاجئين في
محاوله لكسب اصوات القوميين والشباب
والتركيز على التحدي الاكبر وهو اخراج
مناصري المعارضه من حاله احباط محتمله
تسببت فيها نتائج الجوله الاولى يكتشرون
مقاربتك لجدار اوغلو في الجوله الثانيه
اعتمدت التخويف مما سيحدث في حال لم ينجح
وهي معاكسه لنظيرتها في الجوله الاولى
التي كانت تركز على رسائل ايجابيه من
الصعب الجزم باداء هذه المقاربه فالبلاد
تذهب لجوله اعاده في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لاول مره في تاريخها
تتضارب استطلاعات الراي حول من سيكون
الرئيس الثالث عشر للبلاد هذا ما حصل قبيل
الجوله الاولى وهذا قد يحصل في الجوله
الثانيه ويعزوا خبراء الراي العام تضارب
الاستطلاعات لكون بعض مراكزها قريبا من
هذا الحزب او ذاك
هي اشبه ما تكون بمعركه كسر عظم بين خصمين
يقول اردوغان ان عنوانها هو الصراع على
بقاء تركيا فيردك بانها ترقى لان تكون
استفتاء على مصير الوطن هي معركه الفائز
فيها من يقنع ناخبين اكثر بان الغداء معه
افضل
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره انقره
[موسيقى]
الان نعود الى التطورات في السودان ولكن
هذه المره سنركز على اتهام الولايات
المتحده مجموعه الروسيه بتزويد قوات الدعم
السريع في السودان بصواريخ ارض جو
باستخدام هذا ضد الجيش السوداني في القتال
الدائري حاليا مع بدايه عام
ترسخت علاقته باجنر مع قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حميدان محمد حمدان دجله
الشهير بحميتي شرعت انقلاب المكون العسكري
على الحكومه البدنيه في اكتوبر تشرين
الاول عام 2021 في تقديم المساعدات
العسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع وقد زار
حميدتي موسكو لتعزيز العلاقات اوائل عام
2022 وذلك بالتزامن مع بدايه حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا ومنذ ذلك الحين توالى انتشار
فاجنر خارج مناطق الجنوب الغربي في
السودان قربه بلده ام دافوق على حدود
السودان مع افريقيا الوسطى حيث تعدين
الذهب
لقد اصبح من المالوف الان تمييز ملامح
عناصر المجموعه بهيئتهم المعروفه عالميا
وهم يتجولون في محيط مدينه بورسودان
الساحليه لكن حضور فاجنر في المشهد
السوداني كان على ما يبدو اسبق من ذلك
فاجاد يد حاميه مما وصف بالاعمال
العدوانيه الامريكيه ضد السودان كان الهدف
المعلن لزياره الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر
حسن البشير لروسيا اواخر عام 2017
الثمن حسب ما قيل وقتها كان وعدا من
البشير بان يصبح السودان مفتاح افريقيا
بالنسبه الى الكرملين بجانب امتيازات
التعديل وبناء قاعده بحريه روسيه على
البحر الاحمر في مينا بورسودان بوابه
البلاد للتجاره الدوليه بعد اسابيع من ذلك
وصلت عناصر من مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه سبق
لهم العمل في اوكرانيا وسوريا وصلوا الى
السودان ومعهم علماء جيولوجيا روس وذكر
انذاك انهم جاؤوا للعمل في مجال التعديل
عن طريق الشارقه مروي جولد المحليه التي
تعود ملكيتها الى شركه ام انفست الروسيه
منذ اذن اصبح وجود فاغنر في السودان امرا
واقعا وفي ابريل نيسان عام 2018 اي بعد
نحو خمسه اشهر من اتفاق البشير وبوتين زار
يفجيني مؤسسوا ومالك فاجنر الخرطوم
وبعد رحيله تحدثت مصادر عن وجود نحو 100
من عناصر فاجنر يدربون قوات سودانيه
ينضموا الينا للحديث عن هذا الموضوع
من مونتانا مايكل
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
ومن موسكو العقيد فيكتوريا محرر الشؤون
العسكريه في وكاله تاس الروسيه ونبدا من
ضيفنا في مونتانا
واشنطن ادانت الوجود وجود فاجنر في
السودان وسلطت عقوبات هل هذه العقوبات
كفيله بانهاء وجود فاجنر في السودان
يتواجد معكم وايضا مع ضيفكم الاخر اعتقد
اننا نتمنى ان تنجح
المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه وان ينجح
وقفه اطلاق النار
لموقع في السودان نتمنى ان لا يقع المزيد
من الضحايا المدنيين وينبغي الانتقال الى
حكومه مدنيه منتخبات طبعا تواجد
لا يساعد في الحل بل يعقد المشهد ويزيد من
العنف واعتقد اننا شهدنا ماسي لبنانير في
سوريا في اوكرانيا في
في مناطق اخرى في ليبيا ايضا الان في
السودان اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الان ستحاول على حشد الدعم
الدولي من اجل ان يصمد اتفاقه اطلاق النار
من اجل ايضا عدم السماح بيتفاقم الوضع
ليس سرا السيد في موسكو ان سمعه فاجنر
ليست سمعه جيده على المستوى الدولي لماذا
تصر موسكو على استعمالها ورقه في اكثر من
نزاعه في العالم
اولا
فاقنر هي ليست
شركه
نادره الوجود هناك الكثير من هذه الشركات
العسكريه الخاصه في امريكا مثل البلاك
ووتر
وهي الشركه الاكبر التي ظهرت في الكثير من
الدول في العراق وفي سوريا وفي ليبيا وفي
بعض الدول
الافريقيه وفي السودان خاصه لذلك عندما
تتحدث الولايات المتحده عن سمعه امراه
سيئه هذا
حقد للمنافسه ان
ضاقنار ليست عضو في هذه النزاعات فاقدر
يتم
دعوتها من قبل ادارات الحكومات على اساس
عقود مع تلك الدول لا تاتي فاجنر بنفسها
حتى تقوم بنزاعات مسلحه لذلك الحديث عن
سمعه فاقنر هنا لا احد بالطبع يحب
المنافسه ولكن فاجنر منظمه ضخمه جدا تعمل
للدفاع عن المصالح الروسيه ولكن ليس الكل
يحب استقلال وسياده روسيا التي تدافع عن
مصالحها القوميه ولكن لن تستطيع ان تغير
شيء عليك ان تقبل هذا الواقع ولكن اسمح لي
ما مصلحه روسيا في السودان ان تدعم
فاجنر قوات الدعم السريع ضد الجيش ما
الفائده التي يمكن ان تجنيها اللهم مزيد
من الفوائد الخاصه بالذهب مع حميدتي ليس
اكثر من ذلك
المصالح الروسيه يسال عنها تسال عنها
الاداره
الروسيه ان الاداره الروسيه تسمح في
التدخل في مختلف العمليات ولكن كما اكدت
لا تاتي من
نفسها بل يتم دعوتها من قبل رئاسه الدول
المختلفه وروسيا لديها مصالح يجب ان تقوم
عليها في مختلف الدول تماما كالولايات
المتحده وكون هذا شيء لا يرضي الولايات
المتحده هذا شانها
ولكننا سوف نحضر ونكون موجودين كدوله
عظيمه في اي مكان لدينا فيه مصالح ولا
يسمح لاحد ان يامرنا اين نكون او لا نكون
سيد
مثل ما كنت تستمع يعني ربما تلام واشنطن
على ايضا شركاتها الخاصه مثل وغيرها هل
تعتقد بان ما قامت به واشنطن في السابق
ولا احد لم حاسب على مقامت به في العراق
على سبيل المثال وغيرها هو الذي شجع موسكو
على ان تنتهج نفس الاسلوب
الشركه امريكيه تابعت في مختلف
[موسيقى]
الاحداث خاصه في العراق
اعتقد هذه الشركه لم تعد موجوده ولا اعتقد
ان المقارنه الان الصائبه يجب ان اقول
الان ان بعض هي القوه الموجوده على الارض
في باخموت وتحصل على الدخائر من قبل روسيا
وينبغي للمشاهدين ان يرون ما تفعله
في اوكرانيا ولا ينبغي الايصال الى ما
اقوله انا اذا فقط الواقع يتحدث عن نفسه
اعتقد ان الامر يتعلق بمجموعه من القوات
الخاصه بما فيهم ايضا مؤسس الشركه مؤسسه
شركه
وهناك من كانوا حتى في السجن وارسلوا الى
هذه الشركه هو القيامه باعمال نيابه عن
روسيا اعتقد ان هذا الدعم المقدم لبعض
الدعم
السريع اعتقد ان هذا بالتاكيد شيء غير
مرغوب كما تفضلتم في تقاربكم وكما يعرف
الجميع فهذا الدعم مبرره هو الحصول على
حصه من الذهب واعتقد ان هذا يحافظ ويشجع
روسيا على الحصول على حصه من هذه المقدرات
في هذه الحاله السيد
في في موسكو الا يخشى ان
مزيد من الدعم الروسي لفاجنر مع قوات
الدعم السريع سيشجع واشنطن وغيرها من
الحلفاء الغربيين على مزيد دعم الجيش
وبالتالي ربما سنشهد معادله مثل ما يحصل
فيه اوكرانيا الان
اولا
اريد ان اذكر
الضيف من الولايات المتحده ان
بلاك ووتر هي لم تعد بهذا الاسم ولكن
اعادوا التسميه الى اكاديميه وهي شركه
امريكيه
ما تريده الولايات المتحده من الدخول
للسودان ودعم الجيش هذا شان امريكي وليس
لنا ان نتدخل فيه ولكن الولايات المتحده
ليس لها الحق ان تحاول ان تؤثر على قرارات
روسيا ودعمها
فاقنر تعمل على اساس عقد مع اداره الدوله
واذا كان هذا الشيء لا يعجب الولايات
المتحده الولايات المتحده لا تحب ان يضعها
احد في مكانها الصحيح شكرا لضيفينا من
مونتنا مايكل مولاي نائب مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه السابق وشكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من موسكو العقيد فيكتور لطفكين
وحرر الشؤون العسكريه في وكاله تاس
الروسيه وقد تحدثت كلاهما عن هذا التطور
المتعلق بمزيد من
اقحام
لنفسها في ما يجري في السودان عبر الوقوف
مع قوات الدعم السريع وتزويدها بصواريخ
ارض جو وفق الاتهامات الامريكيه والتي ادت
بها الى عقوبات بهذا ننتهي من